I think Donald Trump has been incredibly
selfish with his money uh he's got
something like a hundred million dollars
that he has raised and seems to be
keeping it either for his legal fees or
for his next campaign and I think if
you're going to be the leader of a party
then you've got to pour some of that
money into the races that you in fact
created you always worry with Trump that
he's only thinking about getting
personal revenge for the people who
didn't support his stop the steal
movement and I think that that's you
know I think Trump was a really good
president but I think he's been a bad
ex-president and I am I'm sorry about
that I think it's hurting the party
which needs to reformulate itself around
some of the things he taught them but
can't do that as long as he's getting in
the way instead of helping out
foreign
we're taping this uh just a little bit
before these midterms I mean are you
basically feeling like this you know
conventional thinking is Red Wave and
the house and the Senate they're going
to get everything back win a couple
governorships and then we'll reverse all
this Biden Insanity are you are you on
board conventional wisdom
no I'm hopeful but I'm not uh certain I
think we're going to win the house I
think the house looks pretty good uh but
the Senate is really uh tough and it's a
tough map for one thing and then there's
this the fact that
you know they keep blaming Donald Trump
for picking certain candidates Oz and uh
and um uh Blake Masters and guys like
that but the question is really is it is
that the problem or is it that the GOP
won't support those people they seem to
have pulled money out of Arizona a very
winnable State and I'm concerned that
maybe Mitch McConnell is thinking I'd
rather keep the minority and not have
these people come in and defy me and
rebel against me uh then let's let's
take the Senate back hard to really know
first of all it's always hard to know
what Mitch McConnell is thinking his
heart and where his interests lie but at
the same time I you know I also feel a
little bit like we're being gaslit the
polls are telling us no you know the red
back Nancy Pelosi saying oh we're going
to keep the house you know I wonder if
we're being gaslit a little bit and
maybe the Red Wave will in fact appear
in spite of some of the narrowing polls
but I I am concerned I'd like to see the
Senate go back I think Donald Trump has
been incredibly selfish with his money
uh he's got something like a hundred
million dollars that he has is raised
and seems to be keeping it either for
his legal fees or for his next campaign
and I think if you're going to be the
leader of a party then you've got to
pour some of that money into the races
that you in fact created you always
worry with Trump that he's only thinking
about getting personal revenge for the
people who didn't support his stop the
steel movement
um and I think that that's you know I
think Trump was a really good president
but I think he's been a bad ex-president
and I I'm I'm sorry about that I think
it's hurting the party which needs to
reformulate itself around some of the
things he taught them but can't do that
as long as he's getting in the way
instead of helping out uh is that your
way of saying you'd be sort of Team
DeSantis if if they have to make that
decision ultimately for sure I'd love to
see I would love to see DeSantis run and
yeah I would support him I wish that
Trump were the kind of person I mean
this is truly what they call wishcasting
I wish you were the kind a person who
would say I did my job I came in at my
moment I changed things around which he
really did and now I you know we're mean
that the scientist will be my it will
inherit my mantle and move on DeSantis
is a kind of mini Trump there's no
question about it but he also was a
Statesman he's also a politician and one
of the things people like to say about
Trump is he's not a politician but
that's a profession being a politician
that's a profession and you know you
have to know how to do it you have to
know how to Wrangle people and pass laws
and not just pass executive orders that
can be swept away by the next guy with a
pen I I know I can ask you about the the
walksters and the crazy lefties all day
long and we could do hours and hours on
it and I've watched your videos on
Instagram where you watch videos of them
doing weird things and all that stuff
but let me ask you one thing about that
because of someone as you mentioned you
lived in the Hollywood Hills you you
were in the Hollywood Machine as a
screenwriter and as an author I'm
guessing that you probably had
representation with some of those big
organizations and all that kind of stuff
did did it feel like it was going to
fall apart did you always sense that it
would fall apart and that way I don't
mean California specifically but but the
industry and just the way the culture
War has is just you know exploded
because they decided to not give us
anything remotely honest or reflective
of how people felt about the world
well I was warning about it for 20 years
you know I was saying that it's not you
know we pour all this money into some
you know house race in Ohio but we don't
pour any money into creating novels into
creating movies into creating the
infrastructure that the Arts need uh you
know everybody is on the right is
celebrating the failure of that movie uh
Bros but it's one thing to celebrate
failures of movies that offend your
sensibilities it's another thing to make
your own movies and to also give Awards
uh to artists and encourage them to
artists and intelligent reviews to
artists uh some of that's happening now
it has been a long slow slog but yeah
you can vote for people all you want but
if you lose the culture this is the kind
of thing that's going to happen and I've
I've been thinking as I read the news
now and watching things one of the
greatest Arguments for Christianity is
the people who who lose it become
utterly evil I mean they're butchering
children in the name of a a weird
left-wing gender theory that has
absolutely no scientific backing uh they
keep you know people like Rachel Levine
you know who's to me a walking Monty
Python routine uh you know you know he
comes out he says things well the data
the data and nobody ever says to him
show me the date yeah show me that
because there was no data they couldn't
possibly be data uh supporting the
butchering of children but Andrew they
are the science that's why you're not
supposed to question that they are
science
no you know yeah you know when when uh
Vladimir Putin is screaming about the
Satanism of the West Vladimir Putin who
I think is a terrible terrible human
being and an awful dictator and a
colonialist and all these things but
he's saying that I'm thinking well I
have to agree with him there he doesn't
have a point there so the culture is
really uh at a nadir and what I see
coming forward is basically a division
between people who opt to be human
beings and people who opt for a
technocratic world
um eventually they'll build synthetic
wombs and women will actually become
obsolete as as mothers and it's going to
be people who choose to say no you know
actually women are essential as mothers
that mothers are essential to our
humanity and we cannot farm this out to
these technocrats and that's what I see
in the future I'm hoping uh basically
they'll give me another 20 30 years if I
can get out of here and leave you guys
to younger people to deal with it but I
I do see that coming eventually yeah
well that's sort of why I was asking you
the question about what do you want to
happen to California or what do you
think will happen because I I agree I
think although we will remain United in
that I don't think we're going to have a
civil war in some sort of traditional
sense I just think the the things are
just going to diverge it just is what it
is we've tried very hard sane people to
reverse the wokesters they've made it
very clear they're not going to reverse
and unfortunately the institutions have
shown that they don't have the defenses
uh to defend against it so it's just
going to continue to go in that
direction
yeah and there's the question of money
because what happens in leftism all the
time and I guess we can call this
leftism it's some kind of part of
leftism is the the middle class is
destroyed or moves away so you have the
poor and you have the powerful and
that's what what happens every single
time and that means that you don't have
a tax base and so in order to feed the
programs that keep you in power and keep
the poor from coming and burning your
Palace down uh you basically have to
shift money from other places and so
you're going to see a move by the
federal government to try and take money
from prosperous places like Florida and
like Tennessee and move it to places
that are dying of leftism like
California and that's when The Clash is
going to come and if that is prevented
if that kind of shift of money is
prevented then I don't know I just think
things fail you know leftism fails
everywhere it's tried Scandinavia Russia
you know Cuba everywhere it's uh tried
it's a much harder it's much easier to
enslave a little island like Cuba than
it is to enslave westerners and people
who have a history of Freedom if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell